dans le centre historique de Bordeaux il
se nourrissent des déchets déposés dans
les rues d'après les riverains ici le
nombre de rats serait constant depuis
des années
une utilité pour nous pour la ville pour
nos déchets pour nos égouts mais en
attendant il faut réussir à mettre des
actions en place de manière régulière
pour vraiment pouvoir réguler la
population mais il faut aussi que les
riverains entretiennent leurs
habitations car les rats se réfugient
dans le moindre trou de porte de mur et
dans les caves les services de
dératisation de la mairie affirment
intervenir plus de 1000 fois par an
quant à la population de rail serait
stable depuis une quinzaine d'années
estimée entre 350 et 400 000 individus à
Bordeaux Jonas sibli merci d'être la
responsable technique chez docteur
nuisible donc en France le nombre de
dératisation étant hausse de 35%. en
2022 par rapport à l'année précédente
vous allez nous parler bien sûr de ce
que vous avez vécu avec des rats des
rongeurs mais nous dire dans un instant
vous avez vécu des histoires folles
autour de la table comment on explique
cette explosion du rat pour moi à mon
sens il y a plusieurs facteurs on a on a
abordé le
[Musique]
à être efficace à comprendre quelle est
la stratégie quel est le plan à mettre
en place donc mettre en place pour se
débarrasser des rats il y a de la lutte
chimique donc les différents appâts mais
il y a aussi la lutte mécanique mais
au-delà de tout ça
elle va tout ce qui va être quand on
parle dans les maisons dans les dans les
entreprises ou dans les restaurants ça
va être du rebouchage si on fait appel à
un plombier pour pour réparer un robinet
on va pas simplement nettoyer le sol on
va aussi réparer la chose il faut
boucher tous les trous qu'il y a à la
maison ça fait partie du traitement
il faut boucher tous les trous que vous
avez chez vous même les trous quoi même
dans pas les toilettes bah non et ils
peuvent arriver par les toilettes
j'ai un copain alors il a trouvé un rat
je vous jure que c'est vrai c'est levé
la nuit il a trouvé un rat les cheveux
plaqués comme ça
ma vie que c'est vrai il était sur la
cuvette des toilettes comme as debout
comme un bateau
de l'équipe de France
que c'est vrai que j'ai vraiment un pote
qui m'a raconté il habite à côté dans le
92 et c'est vrai que c'est réveillé la
nuit il a entendu du bruit dans les dans
la salle de bain il s'est réveillé il a
vraiment vu un rat comme as comme un sur
la cuvette des toilettes Thomas avec les
Vosges plaques il m'a dit un rat avec
des cheveux longs
c'est un truc de fou et il est arrivé
c'est possible c'est ça m'est arrivé en
attraper comme ça ouais c'est horrible
c'est encore on apnée il passe dans le
siphon il y a un esprit il y a une poche
d'air en fait dans les cuvettes donc il
finit par reprendre sa respiration et à
la fin il veut plus revenir vraiment en
arrière donc et donc quoi il reste dans
les toilettes
et parfois j'ai un copain il est remonté
il était tranquillement aux toilettes et
là il y a un rat qui remonte
non
non il a juste senti un truc et il a vu
ici le vie il y avait un rare vraiment
qui était là non mais c'est vrai ça
arrive heureusement
spécialiste je vous le dis Gilles Verdez
alors il paraît qu'il y a un vrai
problème notamment à Paris pour les
campagnes de dératisation par par
exemple à Paris ils vont faire un parc
ou un square et donc ça sert à rien
voilà parce que les rats savent en gros
qu'il y a des pièges et ils vont dans le
square d'à côté ils reviennent plus tard
ça va même plus loin c'est les reins en
fait sont très intelligents donc
quand on met en place certains procédés
il faut que il faut les appâter il faut
réussir à avoir la colonie dans cet
intégralité et c'est que comme ça qu'on
arrive à aboutir à quelque chose de
concret ils sont c'est nécessaire
d'avoir des rats c'est enfin tous les
êtres vivants sont nécessaires en fait
sur la terre ça permet de réguler pas
mal de choses mais c'est que
problématique quand ça va commencer à à
sortir à attaquer nos poubelles
peut-être que il faut se remettre aussi
en question peut-être on est vraiment
une ville trop sale c'est une réalité
pour que les gens qui nous regardent
pour éduquer d'avoir des rats à la
maison il faut faire quoi alors déjà il
y a l'hygiène qui est super importante
en fait pourquoi la question c'est
pourquoi est-ce que le rêve va venir
exactement
il a un odorat super développé d'accord
il en a marre de manger n'importe quoi
et ils sont une odeur de folie
un reste d'hamburger quelque chose
forcément il va forcément venir et voilà
il va forcément venir déjà tester et à
la suite de ça il y a toute une de tout
un réseau toute une colonie qui est
derrière qui vont se passer le message
donc au travers des différentes
d'éjections et des différentes tâches
d'urines pour passer on vous entend ça
veut dire que dans tous les restaurants
il y a des rats
la lutte elle est obligatoire enfin ils
sont obligés de m'avoir des contrats de
dératisation pour prévenir justement le
phénomène il y a beaucoup énormément et
moi je peux même venir un peu psycho par
rapport à ça parce que ce que je le vis
au quotidien de restaurant qui ont des
problèmes avec les rongeurs maintenant
la question c'est pas simplement c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire parce que
est-ce qu'on va rester avec est-ce qu'on
va aller se développer et restons bien
sûr bien sûr franchement au cinéma entre
deux séances les pop-corn et tout ils
viennent il y a des rats comme ça
en fait les rêves c'est plus facile que
les souris c'est plus facile à éradiquer
que les souris mais il faut parce qu'ils
sont justement
les coute rien
le reste c'est hyper intelligent donc
une fois qu'on a compris voilà je
t'explique ici il va t'arrêter avec des
problèmes tu préfères te dire voilà où
ton cul par maintenant ou bien je viens
on va se vénère tout ça avec tes copains
il va avoir des problèmes par bâcher
quelqu'un d'autre je vais te donner une
adresse et voilà et tu vas pouvoir y
aller de ma part tandis que les souris
elle s'en foutent ouais je m'en fous de
ta santé
si on fait le bon traitement adapté
c'est pour ça qu'on se déplacement dans
une maison chaque année dans un
restaurant comment ça se passe dans un
restaurant on fait déjà un état des
lieux on essaie de comprendre qu'est-ce
qu'on peut améliorer au niveau de
l'hygiène du restaurant s'il y a pas des
choses à fermer
les poubelles mettre découvertes
le problème des restaurateurs c'est
surtout ceux qui sont ouverts ces jours
sur 7 ce qu'ils ont très peu de temps en
fait pour pour faire tout ça mais mais
voilà mais une fois qu'on a une fois
qu'on a mis en place
il faut essayer de limiter un maximum il
faut limiter la concurrence alimentaire
si on arrive à limiter la concurrence
c'est obligatoire quand même moi j'ai eu
une souris Lola elle était par terre
dormait pas de la nuit et le mec qui est
venu il m'a dit il y a des éclaireuses
qui viennent les petites souris les
petites rondes comme ça ils viennent
voir si c'est viable s'il y a pas de
chance il y a pas de trucs de Stéphane
Plaza quoi
tout d'un coup tu te retrouves envahi
par des une elle est venue il y en avait
une on a acheté un chat et on en a plus
jamais entendu alors c'est vrai que
l'éclaireuse elle sait qu'il y a un chat
alors je sais pas on va on va faire le
distinguer
à 19h54 euh sachez pas d'amalgame
pas de stigmatiser de motivation de la
souris s'il vous plaît non non mais non
non je vous le dis donc là la souris moi
moi c'est ce qu'on va dire on m'a dit à
chaque fois moi c'est ce que j'ai dit je
l'ai déjà dit si moi j'ai dit je voulais
prendre deux chats avec des brassards
sécurité
[Rires]
il paraît que le chat c'est quand même
le
alors il y a pas de l'errance c'est plus
compliqué parce que le rein est agressif
je voulais vraiment des chats avec des
trucs sécurité
la
je peux te dire non tu vois
je voulais pas dire ah comme ça je
voulais genre deux trois ah mais
vraiment tu vois qu'il s'entraînent
toute la maison tu vois à mettre un
mètre 5 CDA ah tu vois
on m'a raconté une histoire que j'ai pas
pu vérifier mais j'avais de la famille
qui habitait à Sarcelles et ils m'ont
dit qu'un jour bon les cavités infestés
à l'époque et ils ont fait ils ont une
idée de mettre un chat le chat ça fait
bouffer
parce qu'en fait ils sont en fait sur
une échelle de 1 à 10 tu mets à 10 le
diamant les dents des rongeurs ça va ça
va couper à 7,5 c'est c'est hyper
aiguisé hyper puissant et quand tu les
mets en meute un peu en colonie
maintenant c'est ils vont ils vont se
défendre c'est-à-dire que nous on moi
quand je vais passer quand je vais dans
des fois je vais dans des lieux ça fait
un peu ça fait vraiment flipper ils vont
d'abord courir ils vont pas m'attaquer
mais si mais quand je suis amené à les
capturer et que je me mets en position
voilà bah ils se mettent en position
d'attaque ils sortent les dents et c'est
vrai que c'est hyper
moi j'ai entendu que les cochons d'inde
ça pouvait faire éloigner les rats et
les souris est-ce que c'est vrai
d'accord c'est pas mal en fait quand il
cuitent les cochons d'inde c'est c'est
comme quand un rat crie et donc du coup
ça leur fait peur et il est parti
non mais sérieux non non parce que là je
reviens à cette histoire si tu prends
trois chats
et que il laisse pas des vrais chasseurs
avec le
brassardes et tu les mets en mode
attaque c'est possible que il laisse pas
la chose se développer bien sûr mais
c'est pas une solution directe c'est
complément il y a deux choses
sont tirés par la farine
deux petits chats non faut vraiment
prendre déjà
coupé pas couper pour qu'il soit encore
qui j'ai envie d'y aller quoi
il a un bout quand même il a que
d'autres un mec dans le dos
le chat il rigole pas du tout quoi il a
un carton bon il est quand même oui oui
est-ce qu'il y a des odeurs qui les font
fuir parce que on m'a dit par exemple
que l'eau de javel dans une maison déjà
c'était pas mal pour les faire se barrer
est-ce que c'est vrai non c'est faux
c'est faux il faut mettre quoi alors
comme en fait
il y a des poudres qui existent mais
qu'on met plus dans les combles mais
c'est pas du tout adapté aux maisons
il faut dire que prie individuellement
un chat ça peut être très gentil moi
j'ai eu un chat c'est j'ai pas eu même
mon chien est moins affectueux que le
rack j'avais bien sûr tous les soirs il
venaient dans mon cou il reste dans mon
cou
le chat le rat a sauté comme ça sur Song
et bam League était tellement dur il a
fait ça Laura est tombé
le mec il dort il en a rien à [__]
regarde plus peur de nous je te dis ah
c'est dans le métro plus peur de nous
regarde dans le dos
il a pas vu
sur la tête de ma mère sur la tête
il est reparti ah non c'est incroyable
est-ce qu'ils peuvent monter en étage
j'ai fait des appartements à Levallois
et c'était au 6e
on a un réseau de canalisations donc ils
longe les réseaux
ils peuvent monter partout
on a tellement en France ça pourrait
peut-être qu'on pourrait peut-être
réfléchir à faire
des choses
les risques quand même en terme de
maladie là pour l'homme c'est quoi parce
que moi c'est ce qui est important au
risque quoi
donc vous allez direct à l'hôpital
doivent pas trop traîner les
appartements entre autres pour les
enfants parce que les enfants doivent
pas avoir
exactement les reins les fonds qu'on la
piste en fait donc il est en laissant de
l'urine et des déjections bah ils
indiquent au prochain congénères il y a
un risque
le doigt dessus et qui met la main à la
bouche après oui c'est c'est pas vrai
non c'est des maladies
la rage c'est par rapport aux puces la
oui c'est ça c'est des puces qui
a la salmonellose
éviter
un homme ils sont hyper inquiets c'est à
Hong Kong et l'hépatite E c'est très
grave
on était plus sur France 2
est-ce qu'on est condamné à l'invasion
parce que un couple de rat 45 petits
c'est vrai si on regarde les chiffres ça
fait ça fait peur ah maintenant je pense
que il y a un moment où j'espère qu'on
va se réveiller et que on va un peu
mettre des actions on se réveille sur
rien
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire est-ce qu'on
peut faire donc qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire des actions communes
chercher à mettre le prix le plus bas
mais essayer d'aller un peu sur du
technique et voilà c'est on sait qu'il y
a de la résistance aux molécules mais
pourquoi elle arrive sur son molécules
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de produits les
modules c'est toutes les mêmes donc
celles qui sont en grande surface et qui
sont très faiblement dosées bah du coup
c'est un peu un vaccin c'est un vaccin
qu'on met au rade donc il faut peut-être
arrêter avec les mauvais produits et qui
nous attaquent exactement c'est ça c'est
ça que tu voulais savoir je rentre chez
moi je tombe sur un rat
que je fais bonjour bonjour
je peux vous servir quelque chose
j'appelle un numéro en particulier
qu'est-ce que je fais voilà il a pas
peur de moi mais moi j'ai peur de lui
qu'est-ce que je dois faire si on nous
appelle on va venir le capturer ça c'est
quelque chose qui vous venez comment
vous le captez
Laura alors moi j'ai une méthode non
j'ai une méthode un peu maison j'ai j'ai
des caisses transparentes de vêtements
et je l'enferme dans un dedans et après
je le retendre la caisse et je vais
faire de tout et je repars avec faites
quoi après vous retournez la caisse et
après il est enfermé dedans il est
coincé il peut plus grimper au niveau
des parois d'accord mais comment c'est
quoi des caisses mais comment ouais mais
si il est dans la maison ici il rentre
pas dans la caisse comment ça fait ah
mais je le fais rentrer dans la caisse
comment ben je le pousse tout doucement
je fais un peu peur je le mets dans un
coin donc je déplace des fois certaines
choses et après je fais un geste vif je
bloque au niveau de la caisse
si on essaye de l'attaquer de l'attraper
forcément il va se mettre en position de
défense donc on peut on peut se faire
baisser après vous pouvez très bien
mettre un coup de balai mettre un coup
de chaussures ça peut faire du mal mais
on n'est pas bien quoi c'est sur
l'humain
[Rires]
qu'on peut donner tout de suite
vous arriviez le rail il se balada il y
a pas de magie il y a aucune erreur oui
bah ça marche rien bien sûr mais
c'est très fort ça marche
les poisons les poisons les poisons ça
marche ça marche super bien alors il y a
plus il y a plein de molécules mais là
c'est emmerdant pour ton chat par
exemple non c'est pour ça
que les autres animaux
[Musique]
en fait on est obligé de protéger parce
que si derrière vous avez moi j'ai le
chien de mon frère c'est un gros staff
de 30 kg un jour il a il a réussi à
trouver un un sachet il a failli passer
non c'est lavage d'estomac donc c'est
hyper puissant comme produit
tu vois c'est juste la sécurité ce qui
est intéressant c'est pas tellement la
voix c'est le contenu c'est quel est le
poison qu'on a mis dedans mais si tu
mets un bon point à mon poison c'est
c'est nickel il va il va encore dans les
bois qu'il est assez con pour aller
encore dans les boîtes alors
en fait quand on fait un traitement des
radiations ça se fait jamais c'est comme
je disais c'est pas de la magie ça se
jamais instantanément c'est on fait un
passage et on fait souvent un passage de
contrôle pour vérifier si ça a bien
fonctionné ou pas dans la lutte chimique
c'est c'est des différents poisons les
mécanique ça va être les [__] et
l'école le problème des [__] et
d'école c'est ça fonctionne aussi mais
et les rats sont assez intelligents pour
que pour voir que si il y en a un qui
s'est pas attrapé ils vont plus
recommencer derrière bien sûr donc en
fait on va utiliser plutôt des méthodes
qui vont les tuer sur du long terme
surtout cruel la colle qui a fait la
mérite Paris avec les JO et tout les
travaux dans Paris en ce moment
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait pour pour se
prémunir de souffler ou parce que
franchement ça c'est c'est 10000
chantiers ils ont sûrement dû faire un
appel d'offre mais bon il est moins cher
et pas les meilleurs c'est c'est ce qui
se passe moi j'ai fait le test j'ai fait
le test voilà d'une fois j'ai vraiment
mis ce qu'il fallait et le devis n'était
pas validé
mais il faudrait déjà des capturer les
relâcher mais quand c'est qu'un un rat
ça va faire jusqu'à 50 petit dans
l'année ça fait beaucoup de rastérisés